ينضم لنا في هذا الشهر المراسل صباح
العربيه فهد اهلا بك كيف هي التحضيرات
والاستعدادات لمباراه الارجنتين كرواتيا
مرحبا صباح الخير الاعدادات الاستعدادات
على اعلى وتيره على اعلى حماس بالامس وصلت
اربعه طائرات ارجنتينيه طبعا هو مو ناقصين
اللي هنا العدد كبير جدا الجمهور
الارجنتين الان الاعلى مع بجانب الجمهور
المغربي
طبعا المنطقه الي امامنا هنا امتدادها
منطقه اكبر منطقه جماهيريه اللي هي سوق
واقف بالامس كانت مكتظه تماما بالاجنبي
الطريقه كله سماوي والطريق كله اهازيج كله
مجسمات كل الاغاني والاناشيد الارجنتينيه
المعروفه مهاجمه الكل مهاجمه ايضا
وذكر خروج البرازيلي تحدي الكروات يعني
الحماس عالي جدا المشجع الارجنتيني يحضر
هنا المسانده المنتخب كما هي عادته من
بدايه كاس العالم ايضا يحضر همم عمل ثاني
مشاهده اخر اخر كاس عالم لليونيل ميسي كره
العالمي والاسطوره الارجنتيني المشجع
الارجنتيني
يثق في منتخب وكثيره يعني المنتخب المشدعه
اجلتيني جلستنا معاهم كثير نسالهم ايش سبب
الحضور هم يعشقون كره القدم رغم الازمه او
الضائع الماليه اللي يعيش فيها
الارجنتين والمشجع الارجنتين لانهم يحضرون
بكثافه بعائلات
ويسكنوا لعده ايام ويشاهده المباريات بكل
حماس وشجع الارجنتين ايضا يقطع 14,000
كيلو متر وهي ما يبعد بين الارجنتين وبين
منطقه الخليج العربي بكثافه لهذا لا
تستغربي من تواجد الجمهور الكبير في لوسين
الذي تجاوز 80,000 اغلبوا من المشجع
الارجنتين يتكون كثير في منتخبهم خصوصا
بعد الفوز الكبير في المباراه الماضيه
والفوز والاكتساح امام هولندا هولندا
القوي جدا والمنظم جدا بقياده فان خالد
يعني كمان فقط
طائرات يوميه الى قطر ايضا لمتابعه مباراه
يوم غد التي ستكون بين المغرب وفرنسا
اليوم فهد بما انه نتحدث عن منتخبين غير
عربيين اين يقف العرب بين المنتخبين في
الدوحه اليوم
[موسيقى]
الارجنتين طبعا اكثر هناك العديد يعني حتى
من الاصدقاء في السعوديه
اصدقائي ايضا في الكويت في الامارات
بيسالوا عن التذاكر من بدايه تحديد
المباراه من بدايه تحديد المباراه
الارجنتين كرواتيا بيسالوا عن طريقه
الحصول على التذاكر هل يوجد تذاكر فاعتقد
انه المتابع العربي والمتابع الخليجي
بالتحديد باميل طبعا الارجنتين همم بشكل
اكبر طبعا هو يامر بتكرار همم اول شيء
مشاهدات ميسي واخر نسخه من ليونيل ميسي
ثاني تكرار الانجاز اللي حصل مع هذا الرجل
الراحل الاسطوره العظيم همم
مارادونا يريدوا ان يشاهدوا الكاس مره
اخرى همم بيد ليونيل ميسي هذا المسمى الذي
وضع هنا للراحل مارادونا اللي حتى ميسي
يعني بعد الفوز الاخير همم صرح تصريح يعني
هو هو قد يكون غريب علينا لكن عندهم عادي
انه همم المارادونا يشاهدنا وتصل لنا
دعواته واتمنى ان يستلم معنا حتى النهائي
احنا نتمنى ان شاء الله نشوف مستوى
الارجنتين اللي صار لنا مثل النهائي
ونشاهد ايضا كاس عالم اخرى همم بايدي
الارجنتين كما حمله
مارادونا وهذا ههه وهذا قميصه
وهذا اخر قميص الضيقه مارادونا همم في همم
كاس العالم 86 طبعا نتمنى المنتخب المغربي
اكيد اكيد العاطفه همم جياشه ومتجه
المنتخب المغربي لكن همم ايضا الارجنتين
منتخب كبير لها جمهور عظيم في كل انحاء
العالم خصوصا همم
العربيات شكرا جزيلا لهم الفوز لارجنتين
ههه